ladies and gentlemen we have a new
edition
h particle security
specializing cache trucks across l.a
do you have any idea how dangerous this
job can be
somehow yeah we ain't the predators
we're the prey
you ready ready
this is your temporary sidearm why is
before we're pulling pistols in the
machine gun fight do you have a problem
i don't know do i it's a 10 grand drop
you should have been back five minutes
ago
they're serious leave this to me
get in the truck next time sorry pal
who is this lunatic
it doesn't feel right
[Music]
it's like he wants trucks to get hit
he's not a cop but if he's not a cop
what is he
a while back we lost two cars a civilian
too
there was an investigation they still
haven't found a scum who did it
you were in an accident my most son
he didn't make it i need to not kill my
son
a tree has been shook and it's been
shook hard
we've scorched the earth always be a
good boy
you started by certainly do anything
what i'm hearing is
you think you've done everything
[Music]
i can see it's gonna be a long night
it's gotta be an inside job
i can do in two weeks
you know what i wish you could do in 20
years do bury grudge
you